should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
the research literature produced by the
faculties of Education in the last 50
years has had a devastating negative
effect on public education in the U.S
time and time again if the faculties of
Education put it forward it was wrong
scientifically and disastrous socially
so why the hell have conservatives gone
along with the game of allowing the
faculties of Education to maintain a
monopolistic hammerlock on teacher
certification I don't understand it the
big problem is that legislators have
really done nothing and they've let
these bureaucracies move
anti-democratically to install this
ideology you have people that their
livelihoods now hundreds of thousands of
people depends on pushing this ideology
within the public institutions these are
government institutions these are
institutions that are are created and
funded by taxpayers and that are under
the regulatory power of the legislature
and so the legislature that has
abdicated they're now moving in to say
hey wait a minute we've let this go go
go
Rogue for too long we need to actually
say these are political questions and
they they by Nature by their very Nature
by their by their essential nature will
require political Solutions not merely
uh the kind of light touch
um you know approach of people who think
that
um you know signing a letter an open
letter is going to get the job done
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone I have the opportunity
today to uh speak with one of Florida's
leading troublemakers you might say
Christopher Ruffo and he's been working
on the education front in Florida and I
want to play the role of friendly enemy
today because I'm very interested in
what's happening in Florida concerned as
I am about the state of education in
general in the West North America Canada
U.S
and also more specifically with regard
to higher education and so I've been
watching the goings-on in Florida with
great amount of interest and I have a
lot of questions and I'm going to try to
push Mr ruffle Chris as hard as I can
today in a you know friendly manner
because I want to
get to the bottom of all of this to the
degree that that's possible and I'm
certainly seeing excesses on the leftist
radical side with regards to the
reformulation of the education system
and as far as I'm concerned something
needs to be done about that but that's
complicated and it's hard to do
something about it without falling prey
to
potential access is on the more
conservative and traditionalist sites
we're going to Hash that out today at
least that's my plan so welcome Chris
it's good of you to agree to talk to me
today and I'm I'm really looking forward
to this yeah likewise it's a it's a
pleasure and an honor to be with you and
look forward to the conversation
so let's start out by giving some people
information about your background and
you kind of sprang onto the scene at
least in so far as I was concerned
just a couple of years ago when you
started really
what would you say pushing back against
the Dei activists on the education front
and now you seem to be pretty integrally
involved in Governor DeSantis of
Florida's
um what would you say strategic moves
forward
on the on the education reform front and
so let's start with a bit of description
about your background and how you came
about doing what you are doing and what
you're doing as well yeah well you know
I think my background is pretty
different than than a lot of the folks
in the conservative world or the
conservative movement
um you know I was I grew up as a kind of
a young man of the left um that was my
politics kind of hard left Politics as a
teenager my my family members were kind
of in a long tradition of a kind of
left-wing and even kind of marxist and
and communist uh activism and uh and but
then over the course of my adulthood in
college and then after college I spent
about 10 years directing documentaries
all over the world for PBS sold a film
to Netflix and other International TV
stations and that left-wing worldview
totally fell apart
um I started working in the conservative
world started doing journalism and then
of course uh I think sprung onto the
scene as you said it with my work
exposing critical base Theory first in
government then in K-12 schools and I
think part of my background that is
maybe even helped make me successful in
this is that I I know how the left
thinks uh intimately
um and I don't think that's true for my
opponents I don't think that they know
how the right things I don't think they
know how conservatives think they don't
think the right does think yeah that's
right yeah I get there was a there was
that great line I think from uh that
conservatism is a series of irritable
gestures
um you know right so condescending and
and I think that you know while you
could let that bother you or you could
let that uh annoy you it actually
presents a strategic Advantage for
conservatives because we know how our
opponents think I think in many ways I
can make the argument on my opponent's
behalf better than they can
um and then they look at us just like
we're Barbarians at the gate and so uh
it's fun and even playing that role a
little bit kind of leaning into it with
a wink uh playing the Barbarian uh for
me has been quite quite entertaining and
quite amusing yeah
[Music]
despite the U.S blowing through the 31.4
trillion dollar debt ceiling last month
the White House still refuses to reduce
spending our national leadership has
buried their heads in the sand but you
don't have to call the experts at Birch
gold today and start diversifying into
gold for over 5 000 years gold has
withstood inflation geopolitical turmoil
and stock market crashes with help from
the experts at Birch gold you can own
gold and attack sheltered retirement
account Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals just text Jordan to
989898 to claim your free info kit on
gold and then talk to one of their
precious metal Specialists with an
A-Plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings text Jordan to 989898 today
[Music]
so let's go back to to to the the first
part of the biographical discussion
there you said that you were hard left
as a teenager and came from a pretty
hard left family and it's definitely the
case there's a famous line I don't
remember who said it is that you know if
you're a teenager with a heart you're uh
you're left-leaning you're a liberal or
a socialist if you're an adult with a
brain you're traditionalist or
conservative leading and I think there's
some real truth in that um also partly
and this has to do with you know your
characterization of conservatism as a
series of irritable gestures one of the
things that young people are looking for
to orient themselves in the world is a
cause that's Noble that they can
identify with and it's really up to the
community to provide that Vision which
is part of their enculturation and
conservatives have done a dreadful job
of that I would say in liberals as well
for like the true liberals not the
leftist type so when you were when you
were a kid teenager what do you think
was specifically attractive to you uh
both personally and and philosophically
about what was being offered to you on
the left yeah I mean I think a lot of it
is just a sense of heroism a sense of
drama a sense of the Romantic you get
all of the mythology of the left you
know an aunt of mine gifted me a Che
Guevara flag that I hung in my bedroom
and you have this kind of heroic image
of the swashbuckling reformer pursuing
social justice holding the rich
accountable providing for the poor and
it is a very attractive narrative I mean
there's no getting around that it's a
magnetic narrative and the conservative
narrative is really one of uh restraint
Duty obligation and when you're 13 uh
that's not exactly something that is
going to inspire you and at the same
time I think that I grew up in
California
um uh in Sacramento and the kind of
Mythology around the University of
Berkeley the Free Speech movement some
of those great uh student moments at the
time was also something that I
gravitated towards I remember as a
teenager my friends and I would go out
and and visit the campus at Berkeley and
kind of be really kind of wide-eyed and
amazed at the the university culture and
so those were some of the things and
then of course my family members in
Italy were kind of old school European
working class marxists and so they would
provide uh you know kind of long
lectures when we would go back and visit
uh you know the thought of Lenin the
thought of Marx the thought of gram
sheet they approached it from a a
theoretical basis that was to me at the
time very attractive because it was
putting an intellectual
frame to politics and so it engaged me
mentally as well and so
um it's an attraction so it's your first
introduction to political Theory really
well so the other thing we could point
out too is that
there is a very real issue at stake here
a couple of very real issues we're going
to give the left it's due so the first
issue is the the pervasive reality of
the unequal distribution of both talent
and wealth and so Marx famously noted
that Capital tended to accumulate in the
hands of fewer and fewer people as time
went on now the
cat the Catholicism make mistake that
Marx made one of many was to assume that
there was something unique about
capitalism in the production of
inequality and there's much more
thorough work done now on all sorts of
theoretical fronts ranging from physics
to economics demonstrating that that
proclivity of resource let's say or even
substance for that matter to be
unequally distributed is extremely
pervasive and so for example it is the
case that most of the world's capital is
in the hands of a relatively few people
but it's also the case that most of the
world's water flows through a very small
number of rivers and that most of the
world's population lives in a very
small number of cities and that most pla
very few planets have almost all the
planetary mass and that also applies to
Stars it applies to your blood vessel
vessels as well a very small proportion
of your blood vessels have the largest
volume of flow that's called a Pareto
distribution and Pareto distributions
tend to characterize a certain
proportion of natural systems and so
this proclivity for inequality to emerge
is real and the danger that Capital will
accumulate the hands of very small
number of people is also real but
but number one it can't it can't be
attributed to capitalism because every
economic system that humans have ever uh
employed
produces a Pareto distribution now but
the problem there is is that if you're a
young person and maybe you're looking
for a romantic adventure and you see
inequality it's going to grate on you
emotionally because who the hell is
happy about the fact that there are
disenfranchised Street people and and
then also people who are even perhaps
you know with a street person you might
say well you've made some bad life
choices but you know what do you say
about poverty-stricken children
especially when they're poverty stricken
in the face of wealth and so the idea
that you're fighting on behalf of the
oppressed is a pretty attractive
proposition for a young person even if
they're not ideologically adult right
and it's it's also a reality that makes
conservatives guilty
when they're faced with the moral
onslaught of leftist activists because
well inequality is a painful reality and
the truth of the matter is we don't know
we really don't know what to do about it
it's very difficult problem to solve and
it's it's a complex the solutions are
complex but then you know you can be
Shea Guevara and you can have a nice
flag in your bedroom and your relatives
can tell you that you are a young hero
in training and like that is a lot more
attractive emotionally than as you
pointed out the message of restraint
Duty and obligation which is kind of the
last thing a 13 year wants to hear when
he's trying to make his adventurous way
out in the world this is a very big
problem
yeah and I'll tell you kind of how My
Views changed and really My Views
changed significantly when I spent uh
five years actually working on a
documentary for PBS uh looking at three
forgotten American cities Youngstown
Ohio Memphis Tennessee and Stockton
California I followed these families in
some of the poorest ZIP codes in the
country a white neighborhood a
predominantly black neighborhood and a
predominantly Latino and mixed race
neighborhood over the course of a few
years and really trying to understand
this question what is driving inequality
what does inequality look like what does
the phenomenon uh reveal about itself
and the answer was actually really my
political Turning Point the completion
of my political education and it's it's
looking at it and saying hey wait a
minute uh it's not just a simple
economic story it's not a story of it
leads to kind of greed it's not a story
of that kind of left-wing ideology and
in fact the fundamental Human Experience
of inequality in America in a kind of
advanced industrial country
um is one that actually is a complex
social store you have broken families
and in one of the neighborhoods for
example 92 percent of the families were
single parent homes so there were no
fathers in the home almost anywhere in
the whole zip code
um you look at the social pathologies
um you know from from depression anxiety
to drug addiction alcoholism
um and then you look at the collapse of
community institutions so those
mediating uh social institutions that
once provided a structure a sense of
meaning a sense of restraint a sense of
direction they've all been evaporated
and all you get is the individual and
the state and the ultimate irony that I
discovered was that in a place like
Memphis they're spending I I believe
something like three billion dollars a
year on means tested anti-poverty
programs for a small population
something around thirty thousand dollars
per family per year so uh enough to have
a median standard of living and yet you
have a complete social disaster through
through and so what that taught me was
you have to look at the society you have
to look at cultural factors and and kind
of economic redistribution which we
already have in this country the United
States spends more than a trillion
dollars a year on its welfare programs
um it cannot solve problems that are
human cultural spiritual in nature
um and so for at that point the
left-wing narrative on inequality those
Simple Story
um I mean just could could not could not
meet the the standard of reality that I
saw and and lived with for three three
well you know one of the things one of
the things that's perverse about the
leftist philosophy and I would say this
particularly about Marx
is that all those socialists even the
labor union socialist types who are much
more forgivable
one of the things they presume is that
well capitalism is bad and there's an
implicit presumption there that there's
actually something wrong with the entire
Monetary Exchange system and perhaps
something wrong with the idea of money
per se
but
all you have to do to address social
problems is redistribute money and that
is an absolutely it's such a primordial
it's such a primitive and
unsophisticated Theory because as you
pointed out if you do delve into these
situations in depth one of the things
you find is that things are so broken
and damaged at the bottom end of the
socioeconomic pyramid let's say that the
provision of money is not going to help
in the least like I had clients for
example who were
part of the excluded class let's say and
they actually didn't do too badly when
they didn't have much money
but as soon as their unemployment or
disability checks showed up their
narcissistic and Psychopathic friends
would descend like a plague of vultures
and they'd be off to the bar for like a
three-day cocaine and alcohol you know
uh uh uh party to the point of
unconsciousness and I'd have clients
that would find themselves face down in
a ditch you know the next Tuesday
morning and the idea that you can just
dump excess resources into a structure
that has no structure is the sort of
thing that a deluded Che Guevara
worshiping 13 year old could assume but
that that bears absolutely no
relationship whatsoever to how much
trouble real trouble is and how little
Mere Money can do about it
yeah that's right and I think that they
also make the fundamental mistake that
they look at redistribution as the
miracle right the Miracle Solution but
in fact production is the miracle uh for
almost all of human history we had we
produced very little per capita and so
with capitalist production which is
presupposed in the Marxist economic
analysis
um I mean this is a miracle uh the fact
that we have the standard of living that
we have the fact that we've been able to
reduce extreme poverty globally uh by
such a large extent in the last you know
30 40 50 years as India and China moved
away from a more socialist and centrally
planned system uh I mean that is a
miracle I mean it's a miracle of human
invention
um and so I and I think that at the same
time you feel a sense of guilt uh um
almost naturally because you see this
great abundance and then you see its
distribution but the question of how to
solve that is very complex it's very
difficult and to to dovetail on what you
were saying it's like I I've spent times
in these poor neighborhoods and then I
found sound like you know you'd see
people at like 1am just like
huge groups of people partying fighting
you'd see spikes in violence on a
monthly Cadence I remember talking to
someone say hey why is everyone out
today it's like well the EBT money hit
and so when you have an infusion of cash
into these communities for example you
can even just see the social patterns uh
you know arrests violence Etc
um and and and you have then you kind of
start to understand okay money alone is
not the solution it has to be obviously
resources money that is I think earned
uh and then also that is in the context
of a culture that has a set of values
that can hold it together and look all
over and I think especially in the
United States
um that cultural net has really been
shredded uh and it cannot be solved like
the way we've been doing it since
1964-65 really the late 1960s by the
time it got off the ground you know the
war on poverty spending trillions of
dollars now has not solved it I think if
anything what I've observed in studying
the history Oracle record and then
studying it it kind of empirically
looking at it face to face poverty is
much worse now even though you have a
higher median income and so we have this
Paradox where we have actual material
wealth poor people in the United States
are richer than almost every other uh
group globally and yet the experience is
much worse and and I I think that in my
travels abroad it's like almost if you
have to choose from a cultural
standpoint would you rather be poor uh
in maybe a developing country buffeted
from some of these things or poor in the
United States which uh in in many cases
it's like a it's like a hellscape you
know violence addiction mental illness
uh kind of shredded uh social net and
um these aren't easy questions uh and
they they certainly don't have easy
answers
we'll be back in one moment first we
wanted to give you a sneak peek at
Jordan's new series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
well you know the part of the
appalling hypersimplicity of the woke
moralist claim is that poverty is
reducible to lack of money and in fact
true poverty is a multi-dimensional
problem and the multi-dimensional
problem is essentially something like
lack of proper placement within a
functioning social hierarchy and lack of
forward vision
and then what happens if people don't
have anything they regard as useful
productive and generous to do that
they're committed to then what happens
is because they can't find meaning or
cersei's from anxiety in the pursuit of
a well-constituted life they default to
impulsive pleasure seeking and then if
you add money into that situation it
makes it worse because there's nothing
that facilitates impulsive pleasure
seeking than money like money right and
so it's it's definitely the case that
well it's a hell of a good time for four
or five days in the bar and I'm not
saying that poor people drink more
although I am saying that people who
drink more and act in that impulsive
manner are far more likely to be poor
and so there's also causal
bi-directional causality constantly at
work in a manner that this is also what
makes me a manner that belies the
leftist claims this is also one of the
things that makes me very skeptical
about the moral uh certainty that the
leftists who are hypothetically on the
side of the poor bring to the to the
table with regard to arguments all the
time it's like well
these this this this this unidimensional
sympathy you have and this insistence
that all of this complex problem can be
reduced to let's say the greed of the
capitalist overlords might do wonders
for you and your ego allowing you to
parade as you know this year's
incarnation of the spirit of Che Guevara
who is a murderous Punk by the way but
it it does nothing for the people who
you are attempting to hypothetically
help except make their lives a hell of a
lot more miserable but you know you get
to feel good about it so that's that's a
small price to pay all things considered
All right so that all broke for you when
you were working for NPR
yeah yeah I started to see so now did
you actually
did you actually start moving in more
say classic liberals liberal or
conservative circles at that point I
mean you must kind of be now at a loss
for a while given that you're
you know your worldview had come under
assault under the brutal lessons of
reality yeah yeah exactly and you know
these are documentaries for for PBS and
and I was kind of moving to the center
moving to the right I went through kind
of a Libertarian phase even uh to my own
embarrassment now
um and my politics shifted and and I
could just feel it that my relationships
with colleagues were starting to fray
people were Whispering you know I think
rufos may be a conservative now you know
very concerned about me
um and then there was a kind of moment
where I had to make a decision am I
gonna engage in politics am I going to
say what I think is true am I going to
face the consequences and you know
ultimately I said look I I was kind of
turning 30 and I said it's either now or
never I'm gonna kind of come out I'm
gonna stake my claim I burned all of my
relationships in the documentary world I
lost funders I had people who had worked
for me as contractors for years tell me
that they couldn't work with me anymore
and so the the documentary world was
just a total dead end I mean
what year was that oh this was probably
like uh 2015 2016 uh when it started to
change so so right at the as the kind of
thing nobody no nobody can shun like uh
like uh what would you call it a a
burned leftist I mean look I I've tried
to maintain a relatively balanced view
of the excesses on both sides of the
political Spectrum but one thing I have
clearly experienced repeatedly
is that the left will shun and exclude
to a degree that's almost un it's almost
unknown on the right I've never had
anyone on the right that I've talked to
refuse to talk to a hypothetical guest
for example and I've had people on the
left they just do that all the time and
I don't I don't get that exactly I think
maybe it's maybe it has to do with the
association and personality between
agreeableness and leftist proclivity so
the Socialist types the lefties are
technically more agreeable and I think
maybe
among agreeable people if you don't go
along with the agreeable game you're
much more likely to be categorized as a
predator
and I think it's also part partly an
Institutional question so something like
PBS something like the art world
something like the cultural World
certainly also the academic world these
are artificial economies right they're
propped up by the state they're propped
up by philanthropic funding there are
limited number of spots it's highly
competitive it's a lot of people that
are very credentialed very intelligent
and they have to find strategies to
fight it out for these limited resources
they see them as zero-sum games whereas
in corporations or entrepreneurship
which are traditionally more kind of
conservative or free market the idea is
well we can create a company with two
people and grow it to a hundred thousand
people
um there's a sense of expansion there's
a sense of possibility okay well that's
a good theory so you think if you view
what you're doing as a zero-sum game
there's always a rationale for exclusion
of course yeah and and you're trying to
move up a hierarchy and there's it's not
competence that's rewarded it's not
economic uh productivity that's rewarded
um in in all of these places it's not
even really an economic question anymore
and and so you can critique marks I
think that's good and fine and true but
the real change on the left and I think
this plays into both what we were
talking about previously in this
question is that they've moved from a
unit of analysis or a basis of analysis
of Economics a material basis to a
metaphysics metaphysical basis on
identity and that's very unstable and
it's so unstable and then you have games
that are not played on hey let's let's
kind of advocate for wages or working
conditions or or or or cash
redistribution you're you're actually
then jocking on the position of identity
and so you have an artificial economic
economically artificial institution
limited positions highly ambitious
people that are then jockeying for
position based on identity I mean it's
like that is a recipe for a real
derivative game in some sense right so
so it's already a derivative of reality
when you're talking about money
but when you're talking about identity
you've you've moved one step further up
the abstraction hierarchy like a
financial derivative and so things get
things get very unstable and and
vacillate a tremendous amount I mean
because the Marxist game as you pointed
out for the longest time and then even
the valid socialist game was essentially
economic like the fundamental playing
the fundamental Battlefield was you know
do what slice of the pie does the
working class get and certainly labor
leaders and people like that who were
genuine socialists in the English
tradition rather than the Marxist
tradition were doing what they could to
be some of them at least to be an honest
voice for the oppressed working class
and also I think as some intelligent
leftists still continue to do and I'm
thinking about people like Russell Brand
we're also pretty good voices to fight
against the dangers of corporate
gigantism and Regulatory capture which
is something that well clearly needs to
be addressed probably probably more now
than it has been that has been necessary
in the last 70 years because that's a
real threat and so all right so now
we've got some reasons for exclusion
laid down so now okay so you announced
yourself you come out of the closet so
to speak as a more conservative thinker
2016 and 2017 that pretty much
devastates your social community and I
presume your livelihood at least as an
NPR documentarist that's for sure and so
then what happens well you know then I
kind of had to scramble right and and uh
you know is it difficult you know I have
a a a family I'm you know starting to
have kids and and and I'm kind of at
this career Crossroads where I've kind
of burned all of the bridges you know
the kind of in of the past and then
um I said all right well what can I do
what am I good at what would actually
excite me what what would be kind of
something that I would want to pursue
and I fell into uh more conservative
circles I started reaching out to folks
and then you know they were really
welcome me with open arms they said oh
you're a kind of you know a Defector
from from the other side and in the
conservative world this is a long
tradition one of the one of my own
intellectual Heroes James Burnham uh was
a National Review writer professor of
philosophy kind of Cold War uh one of
the cold War's most trenchant
conservative critics worked with uh
Richard Nixon worked with uh McCarthy
and uh and you know he was a he was
formerly trotsky's a personal secretary
in the United States and so we have this
long tradition of defectors from the
last moving rightward and and so I was
welcome with open arms and I was
provided some really great opportunities
I said hey you know how to do reporting
you know how to get on the ground why
don't you do some research into the
homelessness crisis in West Coast cities
um I got connected with some of the
magazines and Publications and then I I
just my whole world opened up I felt
like I had the freedom to think for the
first time as an adult I felt like I
didn't have to watch what I was saying
isn't it so well I've experienced the
same thing man because I spend a lot of
time where working with Democrat uh back
room Personnel over the last six or
seven years and hoping to entice
persuade the reasonable Democrats to
draw a line between them and the
radicals especially on the Dei front and
uh
and also to to uh
well mostly that to to draw a line you
know and with very little success but
one of the things that constantly
bothered me because I was also talking
to Classic liberals and and people more
on the right at that time was that
whenever I was talking to even
relatively moderate people on the left I
had to watch what I was saying all the
time yeah and like it look it's good to
pay attention to what you say and to be
careful but yeah I get damn sick damn
quick of walking on eggshells when I've
got something to say especially among
hypothetical peers that are
hypothetically working to solve a
problem it's like I just want to say
what I think and if you find that if
that's going to disrupt our personal
relationship it's like maybe I don't
want to be around you because it's just
too damn annoying and one of the things
I have found it's been a very big
surprise to me that I've ended up as a
conservative spokesperson I am not a
conservative person like I'm very high
in trade openness
although I've learned to be a
traditionalist that's that was hard one
knowledge I partly learned that because
I learned that most social science
interventions go dreadfully wrong I
really learned about the iron law of
unintended consequences yes but one
things that has happened is that I found
it way easier to talk to even
fundamentalist Conservative Christian
traditionalists than radicals on the
left there's no comparison and that's a
very strange thing it's not what I
expected at all and I think that that is
really where we've seen the the flip I
mean uh you know for all of the excesses
and problems I'm you know a Critic of
kind of 1960s but you know they were
authentic they were committed they had
open expression they were trying to push
boundaries and you kind of flip this on
of its head once the left took
institutional control
um I mean it is the most restrictive the
most limited the most restrained the
most punishing Orthodoxy and then you
get this point to the point where you
have now hundreds of thousands of of
kind of Dei agents left-wing bureaucrats
enforcers of the Orthodoxy and they just
repeat the same 10 points I've done
reporting for now a few years on
critical race theory gender ideology
they inherit kind of 10 ideas they dumb
them down they pass them through a
bureaucratic euphemistic filter and and
I mean they're like to decentralized
propaganda Agents from Soviet times I
mean it's like this is the party line we
must say this you know you cannot say
anything that would contradict the you
know the great uh the great party line
and and it's like once I ejected from
that world once I uh opened up this new
terrain and actually frankly once I
moved out of a big a urban center in
Seattle and moved out to the uh a
smaller town
it's like this is where a kind of actual
free thinking actual um the feeling of
Freedom the feeling of intellectual
possibility
um and I think one of the reasons that
my work has been successful is because
um I've been kind of liberated from that
stifling Orthodoxy that cultural milieu
that institutional pattern
um and then you know I I see all of
these folks attacking me you know you
can't say this you can't do this you
know you have to observe this the
Atlantic wrote a piece uh recently that
said it qualified uh endorsement of
Christopher rufo but it was 90
qualifications and 10 endorsement
because these folks on the center left
they know they agree with me but they
can't behave as I behave and and really
that's because I'm much more free than
they are um and I love that feeling I
love that spirit I love fighting these
fights with a sense of doing things that
others cannot even contemplate doing
because they risk their academic
cinecurs or whatever yeah well that's
that's the joy of having a free tongue
man well you know it's also very
perverse temperamentally eh because I
looked a lot at what predicted political
viewpoints from the temperamental and uh
cognitive front because if you're
looking at individual differences in in
people's behavior at the psychological
level you look at General cognitive
ability and you look at personality
those are very good powerful reliable
valid predictors of individual
difference in such things as opinion and
the biggest predictor of liberal left
belief is trait openness which is the
creativity Dimension and what you would
which is why for example leftist ideas
are Rife in places like Hollywood but
what's so bloody perverse about this is
that people who are high in openness
first of all all they really have to
offer is the fact that they can think 10
different things at the same time that
freedom of movement that's especially
true with regards to artists that's all
they have and then what you see on the
left is this stifling Orthodoxy that
makes art dull and predictable it
reduces everything to these 10 axioms
and it seems to fly completely in the
face of what open People creative people
would truly want and so I'm still
puzzling through that I can't understand
yet see it's it's partly that the open
people don't want barriers to
information flow away and so when they
see conservatives putting up barriers of
any type even barriers of category that
that destabilizes them because the open
types capitalize on free information
flow but perversely that that rejection
of the boundaries that conservatives put
up has led to a a situation where well
you didn't want any boundaries and now
all you've got are boundaries around
what you can say and think and do and I
can't see how that can sustain itself
for any length of time on the artistic
front because well it'll just it'll do
the whole Enterprise in but it's got it
just stifle the hell out of creative
producers yeah and I felt that in my
time working in the documentary film
world I would attend the conferences I
would go to the festivals I would
participate in the industry and and
looking around and it's like these
people no one says anything new the
festival programmers are pure ideology
you look at the catalog of films for any
kind of A-list film festival in the last
10 years and it looks like a social
justice syllabus it's you know uh the uh
you know the the kind of transgender
basket Weavers of Madagascar I mean it's
like these things that are so Niche so
absurd and then they're only propped up
because again these are artificial
economies you look at these Sundance
award-winning films
um they have all the prestige they win
the institutional game but then you you
put them on the marketplace you look at
like an Amazon uh film rentals they have
like three reviews that two stars
nobody's watching this stuff nobody
cares it has no actual organic audience
and then one of the big distinctions
that I see
um is it's this kind of artificial
culture versus a true organic culture
and we've created an artificial culture
that is high in openness maybe uh but
really high in intellectualism and
verbal ability and Machiavelli had the
distinction he had two archetypes
there's The Lion and the fox the foxes
um highly intelligent adaptable open
verbally very proficient the lion is
strong tough setting standards kind of
the strong quiet type and I I think that
it's kind of a proxy maybe for for for
for left and right and but the
conservative movement needs people that
have the more kind of fox attributes as
well because look we're in a post-modern
world we're in an information economy
you have to to be able to do the
ideological fights with a sense of uh uh
of skill with a sense of sophistication
with a sense of narrative
um and so that's what I I think we need
we need folks like that that also
recognize the value of the kind of the
the lion mindset which is saying we want
to have standards we want to have
institutions we want to transmit values
from one generation to the next we want
to appeal to human universals we want to
respect our past and our culture
um but we also have to kind of do battle
in the world as it exists today and
conservatives have been really frankly
awful at that
um they thought for many years oh well
we're just going to say you know wave
the flag and say America is great that's
not enough we actually have to engage
conservatives could leave it implicit
right but a lot of what conservatism is
about is what's implicit right and and
because the conservative Mantra in some
sense is rely on what's implicit rely on
what everyone already accepts as
self-evident and of value the problem
now is that all of that is up for
question including for example things as
fundamental as what constitutes a woman
and a man and so it means the
conservatives have to make their ethos
explicit and they have to start putting
it forward as a vision and that's very
hard for conservatives because by and
large they're not Visionary because the
Visionary types are the open types now
you've seen this weird
transgressive reversal on that front
like one of the first things that really
struck me as indicative of how upside
down everything was was well first of
all Rush Limbaugh
when I first encountered him like 25
years ago I thought
this guy is a comedian and he was a
comedian and people took him dead
seriously but he was a comedian he was a
satirist and I thought
how the hell did the conservatives get
the satirist
that's a very strange thing and he was
unbelievably influential and then in
more recent years you have these
unbelievably strange occurrences like
the Babylon bee it's like okay let me
get this right you're conservative
traditionalist Evangelical
Christian
and you're doing satire it's like where
the hell are we because we're not in any
world I understand but I think it is an
indication of the the need well and you
see the daily wire plus doing something
like this too right they're trying
they're starting to get interested in in
the uh in the cultural milieu which is
not the normal place that conservatives
play because that's that's where the
artists are and they tend to be on the
left and so this is calling for a real
radical reshaping even of how we
conceptualize the political landscape at
as level as fundamental as that of
temperament itself
it is true but at the same time I think
that you know Aristophanes the the Greek
satirist Greek humorist was a
conservative right he was making fun of
the kind of a very abstract folks he was
making fun of uh the the the the
philosophers of the time kind of
lampooning them so there is a tradition
but I think since the 1960s we've become
so used to this idea that art can only
be left-wing Free Speech can only be
left wing uh Freedom can only be a
left-wing value but it's really not the
case historically and I think it's
certainly not the case now actually
they've taken all of those values and
they've folded them in on themselves and
so we have this euphemistic culture
whether it's you know a kind of
left-wing conception of Freedom or
left-wing conception of diversity and
inclusion you can go on down the line
and you say hey wait a minute
um you're not actually meaning what you
say you mean all of these things have to
be lampooned they have to be exposed
they have to be ridiculed and that's why
I think something like the Babylon B is
successful I think you have more
comedians actually the kind of most
exciting and dynamic comedians of our
time may not be conservatives but
they're certainly lampooning that kind
of left-wing Orthodoxy and so we're
seeing the shifts the shift now and it's
because the the left has institutional
control look you know government
agencies universities K-12 schools
Prestige media organizations if you
understand the culture and I think I've
documented to this in my reporting over
the last few years
um you know this is pure left-wing
ideology it's the kind of identity
politics it's you know the Angela Davis
style of activism it's kind of the the
the the critical theory
um uh a a style of assessing Society
from Marcus and others this is the
establishment and so as the the
anti-establishment became the
establishment really with the baby
boomer generation
um we live in a new world and
conservatives unfortunately still act
like you know the world is run by you
know the the the guys sitting around the
country club uh table uh that's not true
at all the the world is run by you know
the the PBS employees the NPR employees
the New York Times employees Berkeley
graduates Berkeley grads and and look I
know these folks I have a good
relationship with a lot of people in
left-wing media which is surprising to
folks but I've worked with them you know
they've come to visit me at my home
they've done profiles Etc I've talked to
them on the phone for stories a lot of
these folks actually agree with us they
probably don't agree with my style they
don't agree with my Approach they
probably think it's a little bit
Barbarian my my level of aggressive
aggression and assertiveness
and they they'll tell me you know behind
the scenes behind closed doors you know
you know saying you know I think you're
right I think this stuff is crazy it's
gone too far I've certainly went with my
kids to be indoctrinated in this but I
can't say anything because I have you
know my position at the newspaper I have
my position in Academia I'm coward is
really the fundamental issue I think
that's right say that with all due
respect look I had a lot of clients who
had to reorganize their lives because
they were being tyrannized and they had
to strategize about how to regain
control of their tongue and their life
but the idea that I agree with you but I
just can't say anything it's like what
do you mean just can't it's like you're
sacrificing your soul on a day-to-day
basis and the fact that five percent of
the population who's like truly
radically activists can control the
whole damn show on the left because the
90 percent of people who have some sense
won't say anything is not an excuse by
any stretch of the imagination for their
behavior and I know you're not making
that excuse let's let's segue a bit here
shall we perhaps and and start talking
about
um
you're you're foray into the domain of
critical race Theory the first thing we
might want to do is uh let's play around
with some definitions what do you think
what and and this will get us more into
the political discussion I want to have
with you too critical race theory is a
very difficult uh what would you say set
of Concepts to nail down and I've kind
of characterized that whole General
domain me and others obviously as a a
Pastiche of post-modernism and and
Marxism and out of that comes an
identity politics which is
the Marxist experiment failed on the
economic front and all the Marxist did
was they performed a sleight of hand and
transformed economic inequality and
oppression into
identity inequality and oppression and
just went on with the same damn game and
as far as I can tell CRT is just an
offshoot of that just but you've delved
into it with a fair bit of uh effort
let's say and over a fairly long period
of time so let's start by just talking
about what what constitutes critical
race Theory as far as you're concerned
sure yeah I think it's actually pretty
easy to Define I think there are three
main Concepts you have the social
analysis it's that the United States is
a white supremacist country that uh
promotes the concepts of freedom and
equality but this is merely a smoke
screen for naked racial domination
second the doctrine of intersectionality
says that the world can be divided
between oppressor and oppressed but
innovating from the Marxist economic
axis they say no no it's actually an
axis of identity predominantly race but
also including gender and sexuality and
then the third key component or idea is
well what do you do to fix it uh they
argue that the Constitutional
protections of the First Amendment the
14th Amendment private property uh
should be overridden should be suspended
and then Society should engage in
large-scale wealth seizure and
redistribution along the axis of race
until you have equal outcomes and so
that's it uh it's really not that
complicated sure they have citations
yeah
it's basically Marxism repackaged using
ethnic racial and sexual identity
regards to the notion that they the
entire capitalist infrastructure should
be demolished in wealth redistributed
it's like well it's not the bourgeoisie
and the proletariat it's whatever racial
group or sexual group or ethnic group
that you happen to place in the
ascendancy that's right so
and I think this is mostly due to French
intellectual theorists in the 1970s who
had to abandon their appalling
allegiance to Marxism under the
unbearable pressure of the evidence that
all that ever produced was murderous
outcomes and instead of learning their
lesson deeply which they could have all
they did was they did a slight sidestep
Shuffle and produced all these appalling
theories that the Americans mostly
through Yale University in the English
Department there by the way gravitated
to like mad UCLA law schools have been
at the Forefront of this too and that
damn intersectional Theory to me as
someone who's somewhat versed in
statistics that's just a miracle of
ignorant stupidity because all it is is
the rediscovery of the interaction term
so if you're trying to model a
phenomenon you can use a linear
combination of variables which just
means you add them together and maybe
weight them slightly differently but
then you can also multiply them together
now and then now it's an interaction
term and so the idea would be well if
you're if you're tall and uh big boned
you're likely to be heavy and possibly
Tall times big boned equals even heavier
you could add an additional term and the
idea this is the radical idea of the
intersectionalists that well there's
more than one form of Oppression
operating simultaneously and the effect
might be multiplicative it's like well
Jesus could you come up with something
more obvious than that
and the answer is no and it's like why
do you get tenure at UCLA in the law in
the faculty of law for developing a
theory of intersectionality when it's
it's so bloody obvious from the basic
perspective of
primordial statistics that it goes
without saying like that's that's
supposed to be the intellectual
contribution well you know if you're
black you're oppressed Or Hispanic or
whatever the hell it is Irish but man if
you're a woman you're also oppressed and
then well if you're an Irish woman I
mean look at how oppressed you are
multiplied by endless demented
categories of identity it's such an
intellectual it's so shallow
intellectually it's such an appalling
Marxist sleight of hand that it's it's
crookedness and malevolence can hardly
be overstated but I I think it's
important that maybe I'll I'll disagree
slightly I think that is right I think
it was you know they base their their
kind of their legitimacy not on the
objective value of their ideas which
they reject but on their positionality
so intersectionality for example is
promoted by a Kimberly Crenshaw a black
woman and so she has Authority not based
on the idea but based on her
positionality and then she gives it a
complex latinate term intersectionality
which makes it seem uh maybe more
sophisticated than it is but I think
it's important the question of roots and
I'd like to maybe push back as much as I
would like to blame the French critical
race theory is not based in in any
meaningful Sense on the ideas of
Foucault the ideas of the French
deconstructionists I think if you look
at queer Theory that's a hundred percent
true the queer theorists themselves the
founding generation in the 80s and 90s
said explicitly Foucault is our lodestar
his history of sexuality his idea of
sexual transgression is our our founding
principle but the the critical race
Theory uh uh uh kind of Scholars are a
homegrown in the United States
phenomenon and they say it very clearly
they actually lay out their intellectual
lineage they take it from gramshi the
kind of kind of marks on the axis of
culture but really what it is it's
repackaging the ideas of Angela Davis
repackaging the ideas of the Black
Panther Party black nationalist ideology
and then repackaging uh identity
politics based on the kombahi rivers
statement and other kind of black
feminist literature and so it it's
coming from uh Marxism Marx's leninism
black black nationalism and so this is
the ideology that then they made a
decision in the late 1980s as the as the
Soviet Union was kind of uh just poised
to collapse then it collapsed in the
early 90s the critical race there said
hey you know we can't be uh you know
putting bandoliers across our shoulders
and and and and wearing the the cool um
uh the cool hats uh and promoting the
Black Panther Party we have to take
those ideas and then package them in
euphemisms package them in intellectual
jargon create the idea of
intersectionality which is just a rehash
of Angela Davis's uh women race in class
from the the the the the the the the
previous generation and then we have to
seek legitimacy through the academy
they did this very deliberately they
said we need to get CRT Scholars to
start taking over institutions using the
politics of of identity to start
vanquishing our opponents within the
academy and asserting dominance for
political activism they're very explicit
about it they say we don't do
scholarship we don't do objective
research that is the kind of uh the the
white male toolkit we do left-wing
activism and we're going to legitimize
our ideas through Elite institutions use
the kind of manipulative strategies
within the institution pioneered by
Derek Bell and that's how we're going to
gain power and that's how we can then
filter our ideas from those Elite
institutions down to K-12 schools to the
point where you know you have first
graders in Cupertino California for
example getting the teachers and third
graders rather dividing the class on the
basis of intersectionality into
oppressor and oppressed I mean that they
did it and that's how the the kind of
power maneuvering uh worked and and and
so I would say in in relationship to
your intellectual history so
um we could put marks at the bottom in
some ways although not only Marx and we
could have the French deconstructionists
emerge out of that and then the gramsite
tradition emerged out of that too as
somewhat separate streams in the case
you're making is that the CRT stream is
more properly identified with the
gramsai sort of theorists and that's
just to be perfectly reasonable I still
think that what we're facing on the
culture War Front is a Pastiche of
post-modernism and Marxism and yes but
there's certainly no reason for us to
you know either further that
conversation or to disagree
um so let's talk about Derek Bell for a
minute now
do you want to point out some of his
signal contributions to this entire mess
yeah you know uh Derek Bell is a
fascinating guy I did an entire section
and a book that I'm writing that's going
to come out this summer with
harpercollins on Derek Bell and you know
he's actually a pretty compelling
biographical figure
um he was uh uh you know the first in
his family to go to college he got a
degree a law degree he worked with the
um uh nwabcp legal defense fund he he
ran I think something like 300
anti-segregation cases in the Deep South
and you know I mean really compelling
guy who who I think fought the good
fight at that time he went down into
Mississippi organized uh you know black
families got their kids uh across the
color barrier really shut down the
segregation uh policies of the time in
the Deep South you know and really
courageous person but then something in
his psychology shifted and the great
black Economist Thomas Soul describes it
as you know he he he really abandoned
those principles and then fought not for
an equal Society but for a Revenge
society that was Thomas soule's words
and then he became famous by by
promoting not a vision of racial
progress racial integration kind of a
moving past the racism of the past but
he came up with this theory of racial
pessimism saying that racism was the
permanent and indestructible feature of
American Life
um he he spread these kind of conspiracy
theories that the United States might be
on the verge of what he called black
genocide in the 1990s and then he became
famous from this and so the incentive
structure that fed Derek Bell's you know
academic career really from the 90s uh
to his death and in the uh around 2010
2012.
um was that he was the kind of doomsayer
um he said there could be no progress it
was all an illusion the 14th Amendment
the Constitution the Civil Rights Act
the the Emancipation Proclamation all of
that talks a good game but it's it's
really a myth to uphold you know white
supremacy and even the election of
Barack Obama as he was an elderly man he
said you know Barack Obama is the
president of a white supremacist country
nothing more and so he you see this this
really um generation into kind of a
uni-dimensional paranoia yeah and and he
had a verbal tick towards the end of his
life where he would say on interviews I
might be racially parallel paranoid but
and then finish his sentence and and so
you see this this kind of really heroic
figure
um uh uh just descend into this
pessimism cynicism fatalism and then
he's rewarded by society and really
predominantly white liberal Society
um and and so he's this tragic figure in
my book um not an evil man not even a
bad man but I think a man who succumbed
to uh uh kind of it to succumb to this
this temptation of fatalism that I think
then characterizes the second generation
of Scholars that came uh beneath him
they play cynical political games
they're cynical about the United States
and they cynically use their own
identity as a substitute for their for
kind of creative and and confident uh
intellectual output right which which
they also then decry as as like the
markers for that creative competent
output just as part of the
um part of the white patriarchal power
game like I've seen these charts
recently laying out the uh the
attributes of a white supremacist
Society more or less on the
temperamental front like punctuality for
example and I read through those traits
and I think this is so interesting
because I know that low
conscientiousness predicts leftist
liberal View
so it's high openness low
conscientiousness and all the traits
that are attributed to White patriarchy
are the traits of conscientiousness it's
so amusing and that conscientiousness by
the way is the best temperamental
predictor of life's success it's so
second only to General cognitive ability
and so but what's also interesting is
there are absolutely no racial
differences in the distribution of trait
conscientiousness and so the claim that
conscientious temperamental virtues are
somehow white or supremacist or
patriarchal is only the claim that
conscientious temperamental traits are
characteristic of success it's so
interesting to see so and and it's
deeply condescending to people
operational I mean it's like it's insane
and I think what what what the the
actual the the essence of this point and
the essence of that chart is that these
people who are kind of left liberal
Elites let's say they imagine themselves
as the great kind of cosmopolitan and
figures who have a wide understanding
that that surpasses the backwards you
know traditional American way of life
these people are deeply parochial uh
these people have never seen and
traveled around the world it's like if I
took uh that chart and went to Asia went
to Latin America went to you know Lagos
Nigeria where I've spent a significant
amount of time and say hey look you know
these are really white traits of showing
up on time doing hard work
self-efficacy I mean I would get slapped
and rightfully so because uh you know
this is actually racist uh it's it's
kind of inadvertently racist and and it
takes traits that are uh virtues these
are virtues that that everyone can
participate in and reduces them to a
kind of race essentialism that I think
betrays a total lack of curiosity and a
lack of experience uh with the real
world
look I think if you're constantly
harping about how anti-racist you are
there's going to be a vicious internal
reaction formation it isn't which is the
you know the development of an opposing
Viewpoint it isn't obvious to me at all
that the racism in those charts is
inadvertent it might not be conscious
but it's definitely compensatory it's
like well I'm so anti-racist well God I
might as well be Mother Teresa it's like
well yeah you're probably not and so
that all that unacknowledged pathology
that's still part and parcel of your
world view is going to make itself
manifest somewhere and how about in your
accidental supposition that all traits
of conscientiousness don't characterize
black people how about that yeah dimwits
so let's talk about Kimberly Crenshaw I
read about the third of her I don't
remember which book it was now and she
had a very interesting discussion in
there about the fact that there is
evidence for example that black teenage
girls get disciplined more harshly than
white teenage girls and you know as far
as I'm concerned that could easily be
the case but I read this as an
epidemiologist let's say I'm a
psychologist I'm very interested in the
multiplicity of causal Pathways leading
towards a given outcome whatever it
might be and it might be a differential
School failure let's say among
adolescents we could say adolescent
girls say one subset of that is more
stringently disciplined black girls now
she puts her finger on a real problem
but then she does what all these bloody
radicals do is she attributes it to the
same single cause she says well it's all
systemic racism
and I think well wait a second here
first of all it's probably not all
anything it's probably quite a few
different complicated things here's one
for example
so black girls tend to hit puberty
earlier than white girls
it's a reliable finding and then
fatherless girls tend to hit puberty
earlier than girls with fathers and the
difference there is about a year and no
one knows why it's a very complicated
problem and what that means is so
imagine that your black girl without a
father now you're going to hit puberty
say around the age of nine or ten
something like that and that might mean
that by the time you're 11 you look 17.
now one of the concepts there's two
consequences of that one is you're a lot
more physically intimidating if you get
upset
and number two you're a lot more likely
to be held to a high standard of
behavior like imagine 11 year old who
looks nine compared to an 11 year old
who looks 17. like at first glance who
are you going to demand more of and also
be more intimidated by by the way and so
but Crenshaw she has no interest in that
at all she does a perfectly good job of
pointing out the problem and there's all
sorts of problems in racial disparity
with regards to outcome that permeate
like every culture that's a real problem
but then to reduce that to the same old
trite formula to me indicates well the
absolute shallowness of her scholarship
which is really quite appalling All
Things Considered but also this
insistence on the radical side that you
only need five explanatory principles to
account for everything that's gone wrong
with the entire world five they only
need one I mean they they found their
magic wand that's it yeah yeah yeah it's
basically the assumption that power
governments every human relationship and
and the question is not you know the
question even the language
overrepresented and underrepresented is
so misleading because it assumes that
every distribution is going to be
proportionate to the proportion the the
percentage in the population and the but
the question is not you know okay we
have say a statistical reality that uh
black students are are have more
disciplinary proceedings against them in
K-12 great but the real question is not
is it proportionate to the number of the
population the question is well is it
proportionate to the the behavior and
then once you start asking those
questions you may get a different a
different set of of equations a
different set of assumptions and then
you can say hey is there discrimination
that's certainly a question worth asking
you can control for other statistical
variables variables and try to try to
figure out what what percentage of or
What proportion that has to do with it
but it it's like
um a a kind of statistical blindness an
unwillingness to say is there um does
behavior and consequences line up which
is really the number one thing and also
the thing that you can control because
you you can actually say you know if I
believe that my behavior will be met
with consequences
um and I also believe that I have agency
over my own behavior not perfect agency
not 100 but at least some control you're
giving people a sense of what they can
do but if you're Outsourcing it to say
whatever have happens that is bad in
your life it's the problem of the
oppressor it's the problem of the yeah
you know the white male the white male
super the white male superstructure
um you're creating also a sense of
fatalism for people and I saw that so
much in my reporting it's like you're
not doing anyone every any favors by
saying you know whatever you do Derek
Derek Bell says this you know whatever
you do you're always going to be you
know uh you're always going to be
disadvantaged you're always going to be
punished you can never make it you can
never be treated fairly tell that to the
Nigerians yeah it doesn't seem to work
very well on them they do perfectly well
in the United States that's right
yeah a whole host of racial groups I
mean all of the the top performing
ethnic groups in the United States are
racial minorities and uh I think the
question is well you know uh let's see
what they're doing uh let's figure out
what what cultural traits What Behavior
what patterns what values that they that
they they promote uh and let's let's
copy them you know I I see that all the
time I always try to look at different
different people and say hmm this person
seems to be doing you know better than I
am in this in this Pursuit why
um you know and and how can I emulate
that how can I copy that how can I how
can I learn from this
um but but we have a kind of culture
that says no no we we don't want to
learn at all we just want to offload we
want a scapegoat we want to create
theories to excuse
um any kind of uh uh sense of
possibility for people and and to
promote that to kids is really what
pisses me off and look you're promoting
kids into a worldview that is that that
hates the United States that that that
says you're going to be either an
oppressor who should feel guilt and
shame or a victim who should feel a
sense of hopelessness and and and
fatalism
um and then you're you're giving kids no
Pathway to uh achieve their potential
and it's like this is left wing this is
Progressive no no no this is not
anything of the sort and I think that's
why we have to push back to the maximum
extent possible to say get this out of
the classroom that okay now there now we
can move into the more political realm
now you've been working with the Florida
government with fairly closely with
DeSantis as I understand and you guys
have started to legislate moves against
well let's say critical race Theory just
you don't walk us through that first
tell me exactly what's going on I'd like
to know what exactly is being done on
the legislative and practical front in
Florida and we've already outlined some
of the thinking behind that and then
let's delve into that a little bit yeah
it's Florida but it's also actually now
22 States who've adopted policies to
restrict
not critical race Theory most of the
almost all the legislation doesn't
mention critical race Theory by name but
it's restricting racial scapegoating
race essentialism and race-based
harassment so it's protecting students
uh from really a violation of their
civil rights and the legislation uh in
in Florida and in many other states says
look
um you can't you can't promote the idea
that one race is inherently Superior to
another you can't promote the idea that
a student should feel a sense of
historical blood guilt because of his or
her uh ancestry uh you can't say that
one racial group is essentially
oppressive in nature and so in essence
it is recapitulating or really making
more concrete and more specific
prohibitions that are already uh in
civil rights law from the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 and it's responding to this
specific problem because we we have it's
rather it's offering this specific
solution in response to a specific
problem you have schools that are
promoting a racial scapegoating to kids
and look these are public schools these
are kids that are in many cases
compelled to be there by the law and
then and then they're teaching other
people's children without their consent
without the consent of the governed that
they are somehow evil or oppressive
because of their skin color because of
their ancestors and so
um I've worked hard to just say you know
what uh the first step in this reform
initiative is just to say no you can't
do that the people have what is that
legislation what does that legislation
look like and where as and is it aimed
specifically at the K-12 system or does
it also include higher ed and other
institutions it depends on it depends on
the state but you know my point of view
and what I've worked on at Manhattan
Institute with my colleagues on model
policies is to say that in the K-12
environment the state the government the
people have an absolute right
um to create the curriculum to create uh
inhibitions to create a a a core of
ideas and values that are transmitted
through the state from one generation to
the next right from voters to to
Children
um and so I think that there is really
and the Supreme Court has agreed uh you
know Public School teachers are are
state employees
um and they do not have First Amendment
rights in the classroom that's
established Supreme Court precedent and
the state already in every state sets
the curriculum they say these These are
the values of the of the state these are
the the specific pedagogies that we're
going to use these are the actual
lessons and materials that we'll be
promoting and so we know that we have a
really absolute authority to design a
curriculum that reflects the the the
sentiments and reflects the will of the
voters through their elected uh
representatives in the legislature in
higher ed it's a different story there
is a bit more autonomy there's a bit
more freedom in the classroom the the
the the the uh jurisprudence the Supreme
Court precedent uh precedence is a
little bit more complicated so my view
is saying hey we have an absolute right
because these are kids these are not
adults to to to to kind of shape what is
transmitted in the classroom with very
clear principles
um I think it's less so in the in the
higher education space my own preference
is to say autonomy in the classroom but
we have a absolute right to reshape the
bureaucracy so those academic
departments the Dei departments the
diversity statements the kind of
left-wing loyalty Oaths and what have
you and so it's different in my view
K-12 in the University but the the
fundamental bottom line is this
um you know the education system in the
United States is not a free market the
state controls 90 of K-12 and
approximately 75 percent of the higher
education Market it is a oligopoly it is
a kind of quasi-monopoly
um and the public which pays for it
which Charters it has an absolute right
to regulate restrain and limit their
government
uh and and so um I think we're on strong
philosophical grounds we're on strong
practical grounds and pragmatic grounds
and we're on strong on the grounds of
public opinion and I said I think that
um uh the the the question is is you
have left-wing ideological hegemony in
our public institutions even in uh
conservative States what can we do about
it how can we actually push back how can
we get some of these pseudo-scientific
and and really divisive ideologies
um out of our institutions uh before
they really uh uh uh you know harm or
really do do do a kind of uh educational
damage uh to to our kids
okay okay so so let me ask you a couple
of questions on that front so the first
is
here's a mystery
so people on the
Centrist liberal front and on the
classic conservative front the
traditionalist conservative front
um
are concerned about institutional
capture
so I've thought this through where's the
fulcrum point for institutional capture
and as far as I can tell given that 50
of the typical State's budget
is spent on education
The Leverage point is capture of the
education system and then you might ask
well because that's 50 of all the money
that's spent at the state level then you
might ask well who's captured the
education spending and the answer is
well
teachers and administrators that are
associated with the public education
system then you might ask well who's
captured them
and the answer to that is well the
faculties of Education how well they
have a monopolistic hammerlock on
teacher certification
and then the question is well why
like the faculties of Education they
produce the litter the the research
literature produced by the faculties of
Education in the last 50 years has had a
devastating negative effect on public
education in the U.S time and time again
whole word reading learning styles the
self-esteem movement multiple
intelligences like you name it if the
faculties of Education put it forward it
was wrong scientifically and disastrous
socially they attract terrible students
unconscientious students most most
particularly who are attracted by the uh
what would the blandishments of being
able to get a cynic cure position with
plenty of vacation and a
well-established pension without any
academic Excellence whatsoever and
they're woke to the hilt so why the hell
have conservatives gone along with the
game of allowing the faculties of
Education to maintain a monopolistic
hammerlock on teacher certification I
don't understand it well you know I mean
they had uh for for a long time but
that's that's changed in Arizona and
Florida and many other states they're
revamping the certification I've worked
with folks and I've always advocated to
actually just get rid of that
certification cartel altogether and and
saying hey look if you have a bachelor's
degree in physics uh you're qualified to
teach physics at a at a high school
level for example
um and conservatives are doing that but
the problem is that while that was the
initial entry point and we know that
from the literature of of of the
critical pedagogist that was literally
their plan they laid it out absolutely
the 90s they implemented it they have
you know the kind of dominance over that
but well that was the Genesis or the
origin it's almost you know and we
should fix it yes but it's now a small
part of the problem because you have the
teaching core you have the teachers
unions you have the administration you
have the Dei bureaucrats you have the
the actual pedagogical material that is
created and so you can't simply say that
was the Genesis of the problem we can go
back and and solve the Genesis and
everything else will evaporate you now
have a multiplicity of of of kind of the
the locus is not singular anymore of the
problem and so we actually have to do a
lot more and the biggest problem though
even we're even worse than the the
capture of the ed schools is that these
are centralized bureaucracies that are
in theory accountable to the Democratic
votes of the people legislatures
actually have oversight the big problem
is that legislators have really done
nothing and they've let these
bureaucracies move anti-democratically
to install this ideology look
no none of the legislators in red States
said we want to have mandatory Dei
departments at all of our K-12 schools
none of them voted for a critical race
during the curriculum none of them voted
for a radical gender theory in in
Florida in in uh in Tennessee in Texas
but the activists within the state
sector moved against the Democratic will
of the people uh without the consent of
the government and installed them
through a bureaucratic infiltration
let's say and so if that is the status
quo and I think it's undoubtedly it is
I've done the reporting it's been
documented over and over that's the
actual question what do you do about
that you have a a bureaucracy that has
now gone totally Rogue it has
overstepped its autonomy it has totally
transgressed the values of the public it
is it has acted without the consent of
the legislature this is a political
question and our friends in the center
left
um really what their aversion is to is
to conflict uh they maintain this
position as the enlightened Centrist
they feel feel like if they explain it
well enough they feel like if they go on
a podcast they feel like if they if they
can you know write a a jazzy paper that
that the world will conform to their
good thinking
um that's never how it works you have
people that their livelihoods now
hundreds of thousands of people depends
on pushing this ideology with Indians
public institutions and so the question
is what do you do in that case and the
kind of classical liberal solution is a
Dodge because what it does is it avoids
the political nature of the question
um these are government institutions
these are institutions that are are
created and funded by taxpayers and that
are under the regulatory power of the
legislature and so the legislature that
is abdicated is now starting to move in
I think you know through my work through
Governor DeSantis or other state
legislators they're now moving in to say
hey wait a minute we've let this go go
Rogue for too long we need to actually
say these are political questions and
they they by Nature by their very nature
by their by their essential nature will
require political Solutions not merely
uh the kind of light touch
um you know approach of people who think
that
um you know signing a letter an open
letter is going to get the job done okay
so let me let me push back as hard as I
can against that please I I do want to I
do want to get to the bottom of this as
much as possible so okay
it seems to me that the reason that the
public education system worked as well
as it did for as long as it did which
wasn't that well but wasn't disastrous
let's say was that
you could make the assumption that the
bulk of teachers and administrators
first of all that the administrator
teacher ratio wasn't observed the way it
is now but also that the bulk of
Administrators and teachers broadly
shared the same set of values as the
public that they were whose children
they were educating
and so the reason the system worked is
because that shared value system
actually was in place not because
legislatures had insisted that the
teachers teach something that was in
keeping with the standards that obtained
in the general public and now like your
claim and I'm not disputing the claim at
all is that the system has tilted
insanely far to the left and that it's
no longer in sync with general public
sentiment and that the solution to that
is intervention at the legislative level
now I don't think it was legislative
intervention that established the
effective
axioms of the education system to begin
with no I I I I just I totally dispute
that of course it was okay I mean look
at the state government controls the
curriculum the state government creates
the institutions of public schools uh I
mean it's like the the actual curricular
materials yes it was consonant with the
cultural values of the majority at the
time uh yes it was uh uh perpetuated not
through the letter of the law only but
through the kind of invisible processes
and agreements yeah and implicit
cultural assumptions but look uh you
know they also said these are our
schools we have a pledge of allegiance
we do X Y and Z these are the subject
matters these are the textbooks that we
choose and so at all we had a a kind of
agreement with the legislative and then
the implicit cultural
um yeah but but you cannot deny that
these were all initially legislative
Creations I mean legislators spent a lot
of their time uh school boards again
these are elected kind of mini
legislatures for for school districts
they choose the tech textbook they
choose the lesson plan they choose the
start time every decision that they make
politically which is again the ultimate
authority over the public schools since
they were created is a political
decision right but it does rest on that
concordance say it and and look again I
I take very little issue with anything
that you just claimed I think the
central concern that has been bothering
me is this is the concordance issue like
it isn't obvious and this is also why I
was concerned more about eradicating the
teacher certification hammerlock by the
faculties of education is that unless
like it's very hard to legislate
morality even within a system so for
example and maybe we can walk through
exactly how you're doing that like if
there are legislative means for example
to reduce the Dei bureaucracy how
exactly is that going to play out like
how do you identify the Dei
proponents I mean some of them are going
to have it in their name but lots of
them aren't I don't understand how this
is going to be implemented at the level
of detail and how do you know that the
players here aren't just going to shift
the terminology on you sure I can get
into that but I think that the
presupposition there is that you're
saying that it's hard to legislate
morality but but but that's absurd it
has always been in the western tradition
the law sets the moral rules I mean that
that's going from a kind of biblical
basis to the founding fathers of the
United States
um you know they said that this the
function of law is to establish you know
of course limited government but also to
establish uh to establish a moral
framework with in which citizens can
then live out their lives and you know
the founding fathers were clear they
said that the purpose of government the
purpose of law is to allow people to
pursue happiness not meaning a
Libertarian vision of Happiness not
licensed to do whatever they want but as
George Washington said happiness and
virtue they go together the Aristotelian
idea of virtue and happiness in the
American founding was was deeply United
and so the purpose of law is to say you
know don't kill don't steal don't do
this those interdictions are essentially
moral prohibitions to establish a moral
framework but to the specific question
is really a technical question how do
you define Dei departments yeah you know
look with Manhattan Institute I worked
with a team of very smart lawyers from
Harvard and Yale and other places we put
together a model policy that does
exactly that part of it is actually
delineating what it is but but really
what it is is saying these are the
behaviors that we do not permit the
government can no longer spend money on
uh diversity statements which function
of left-wing loyalty OS the government
can no longer spend money on mandatory
diversity training which functions as
ideological indoctrination the
government can no longer tip the scales
on the basis of identity so it can't
discriminate for or against individuals
on the basis of their group identity and
then the government can no longer spend
money on these specific uh principles
behaviors and actions uh that are that
that constitute diversity equity and
inclusion and so the lawyers spent a lot
of time figuring out specifically what
the what the transgression is all right
well what do we not want uh what what
actions are we seeing and yeah they can
relabel they can move but ultimately
um we we get past that linguistic shell
game the left loves to change the
terminology at a quick rate because
their ideas underneath them are
unpopular their their actions are
unpopular their policies are unpopular
so we actually don't don't operate at
the at the level of just the linguistic
shell we say what are the specific
violations and so this is civil rights
law right so the civil rights law has it
kind of codifies prohibitions on racial
discrimination well what's racial
discrimination well we we've able we're
I mean we're still working on it I don't
think we defined it adequately but we're
still working to figure out these
ongoing questions but it should it it
that is a kind of the a cause and I take
your concern seriously but it really
just means let's be very careful let's
be very deliberate let's make sure that
we're doing in a technical manner the
right things but it doesn't undermine
the actual fundamental principle at all
it doesn't even touch it it's that these
EI programs were not created
democratically they violate the consent
of the governed and the legislature the
people through their elected
representatives have an absolute right
to restrain limit and regulate their
government and and so sure we can debate
the details uh if we can get the lawyers
you've answered one of my concerns quite
effectively I would say because what I
was concerned about I think primarily
was
well the potential misuse of government
intervention in systems that should be
granted a certain amount of autonomy
because you can see how that would go
wrong but more particularly I was
concerned that the definitional
framework used to address concerns with
Dei and CRT would remain at the level of
abstraction and therefore become too
amorphous and loose like if you've
actually nailed it down to much more
specific exemplars of behavior infection
then you've actually differentiated the
problem down to the appropriate micro
level of analysis yes do you have any
evidence that what you've been putting
forward
how do you how are you going to measure
the success or failure of your of your
legislative Venture well well you know
you know I think that will ultimately
measure the successor failure on uh can
we can we get these things through the
legislature can the bill that emerges
and get signed by Governors around the
country
um is it does it is it kind of is it
faithful to the vision that we've put
out in our policy papers
um and then you can actually just see
the cultural change that that that
Cascades down from the change of law
you're going to see depart these
bureaucratic departments get shut down
uh I think that you're going to be able
to measure uh the kind of jobs and
initiatives that get closed and get
removed from the University and then
you're going to see very simple if you
say no diversity statements are the
universities doing diversity statements
or not if you say no mandatory kind of
race re-education training are they
doing it or not if you say no racial
discrimination against against
individuals based on their identity
categories
um you can then see is is the is the
University complying and so the
compliance Quest question is not it is
is is really
um if we design a law that is successful
if we restrict not just language but
actual behavior
um I think it'll be fairly easy to
measure on the back end not without
problems not without adjustments not
without going back and and amending it
is there an assessment and measurement
strategy in place because one of the
things I see constantly on the political
front is that people put into place
policies that are designed to produce a
particular end in your case for example
let's say reduction in number of
bureaucrats who are employed by the Dei
Dei or die bureaucracy but that there's
never any real attempt to measure that
to see if the Implement implemented
policies produce their intended action
and and and very little else let's say
yeah yes I mean for sure and and what
I've what I've proposed at new College
of Florida where I'm now a trustee On
The Board of Trustees um is that we're
gonna I'm moving to abolish the
diversity equity office to kind of just
phase that out entirely to adopt these
principles against diversity statements
coercive training programs racial
discrimination and then I'm also moving
to create a very small office doesn't
need to be huge but a a department or an
office of equality Merit and
colorblindness that says these are our
positive principles we're going to
actually have embedded in the in the law
of the institution and the regular
regulatory code of the institution we
have to promote equality so equal
treatment as individuals we have to
promote Merit judging people not on the
basis of identity but on their rigor of
scholarship or Effectiveness or
competence and we have to have
colorblindness throughout the university
and all of our processes and so by
creating this small office I think in at
new college is a small could be just one
one person maybe two people tops we can
then have reports to the Board of
Trustees on a regular basis we can have
investigations as necessary we can have
compliance and and Regulatory rules to
say hey look are we living up to our
values not just of abolishing yeah
that's the first step but actually
presenting a framework of equality Merit
and colorblindness consonant with civil
rights law consonant with the 14th
Amendment consonant with the spirit of
the Declaration of Independence and and
that's going to be the values by which
we govern this institution and we're
going to have of course because it's a
bureaucracy some level of compliance so
that I get a report at the end of every
quarter every year as a trustee hey this
is where we're we're doing a good job
this is where we might be falling short
this is an update on how we're complying
with these principles
so there there are guidelines set
forward by the American Psychological
Association with regard to the
assessment of Merit so people who are
hiring are compelled by law particularly
in the U.S to hire using measurement
techniques that are demonstrably related
to the job outcome desired and so
there's actually technical ways of going
about that and so and I know this
literature quite well so you have to do
a job analysis which is well exactly
what are the functions that are required
for someone in this position so for
example for a researcher it might be uh
papers published per year in journals
above a certain threshold of quality
um combined with number of courses
taught combined with ratings by students
and peers of the quality of those
courses
then you can establish a set of
predictors that predict that outcome so
for example for researchers it would be
well if you want good scientific
researchers one of the best things to
analyze in a potential candidate for
employment is number of Publications
co-authored or authored as a graduate
student during PhD training that would
be research dossier then there'd be a
statistical relationship between the
number of papers published in graduate
school and the eventual number of papers
published as a full-fledged researcher
and that's actually a technical
definition of Merit and so then
merit-based hiring would use
processes would use measures of
Behavioral and perhaps temperamental
factors that were tightly tied
statistically to the desired outcome
that's a technical definition of Merit
do you think that you have people in
place who know the measurement
literature well enough to actually come
up with a definition of what constitutes
Merit that isn't merely that doesn't
merely fall prey let's say to the same
semantic ambiguity that you might fall
prey to if you were trying to abolish
CRT rather than these behavioral
measures that behavioral indicators that
we talked about yeah I of course I I I I
I I I'm very confident because look
um you know academics are very smart
academics are intelligent people if you
set the standard hey we need to actually
work on the objective categories of
Merit this is the rubric this is how we
judge candidates this is the process
um you know it's certainly within realm
of possibility and we know that because
that's how it used to be but how it is
now and I just finished I'm just
finishing up doing a series of reports
on these programs in Florida's public
universities I I analyzed a document
from uh the University of Central
Florida it's called equity-based hiring
uh uh or inclusion inclusive-based
hiring and they say specifically Merit
is a quote myth they say it's a harmful
heuristic they say you can't be
measuring people on Merit It's actually
an oppressive structure and then in
their documentation officially they say
you have to uh measure people you have
to recruit people on the basis of
identity you have to filter people on
the basis of of diversity statements so
loyalty owes to left-wing ideology you
have to Pepper the job description
options with social justice buzzwords
like race Equity social justice Etc and
then at the end of the process you have
to have a quota of at least one woman
and one minority on the final selection
for the job and if you can't get that
race and sex quota you have to scrap the
hiring process and start at the
beginning and they have then guidance on
on the metrics that they want to hit and
so we have to choose as as the public as
the as the ultimate authority over
public institutions we have to choose do
you want a hiring system based on on on
on identity quotas and political litmus
tests or do you want to have a hiring
system based on Excellence of
scholarship and demonstrable Merit
and look people are smart they're
adaptable if you set the standard
they'll figure out ways to to meet it
but right now we have the worst of Both
Worlds we have officially in our law
anti-discrimination but unofficially uh
the de facto law of our institutions is
explicit and purposeful race and sex
discrimination yeah in service of
left-wing ideology and so we have a very
sin we have a very clear problem uh we
actually have what is really at heart a
violation of the very basic social
compact that defines our our Democratic
institutions I I mean you know John
Locke would would his head would explode
if you see if he saw what's happening
you say this is a violation of our basic
constitutional structure and the the
Centrist position which is well you know
we can't do anything don't get the
legislature involved we the government
should not interfere with the government
is such an abdication that it actually
enables tyranny because if the
government is acting against the people
without the consent of the people
through their legislature years to
pursue its own ideological ends that is
the definition of tyranny and yeah it's
a kind of soft equity-based tyranny but
it's tyranny nonetheless and it
undermines the basic structure of our
democracy and I think Governor DeSantis
what he's doing ultimately
is he's restoring Public Authority over
public institutions
um all of the the BS about that this is
a government ovary that's ridiculous the
government determines the government you
can't you know it's like saying the
people have no authority to regulate the
government I mean it it's so tyrannical
it's so totalitarian it's like the the
DeSantis move at heart the actual
substantive core of it is reinvigorating
the Democratic structures reinvigorating
legislative oversight over public
institutions and giving the people a
voice in the constitution of of the
institutions that teach their children I
mean if if we cannot have that
um uh I mean we should give up democracy
has lost any kind of substantive meeting
it's procedural and intellectual and
kind of phantom democracy only
well Christopher I'm going to leave you
with that last word that's pretty damn
good closing statement uh it was a did I
persuade you though that I think that's
the key question for me is uh are you
sorry to support the legislation to
abolish Dei abolish diversity statements
abolish uh uh uh uh mandatory
ideological training abolish racial
discrimination in public universities do
I have your support
well look what I would say about our
conversation today is that you addressed
all the concerns that I had I wasn't
doubtful about the necessity for what
you were doing to begin with
you know I was concerned about the level
of analysis that was being uh utilized I
was I was concerned that it might be too
vague and that it could devolve into
something like you know a conservative
Witch Hunt on the right because it isn't
necessarily the case that it's going to
be you pursuing this in 10 years it
could easily be someone who doesn't have
anywhere near your intellectual capacity
and so that bothered me it's not easy to
put constraints around a set of ideas
and I tried to torture you today as best
I could on that front and I think you
responded you know with exceptional
detail and Clarity and so I'm feeling a
hell of a lot better about the situation
I don't have any questions left that I
haven't asked you and that you didn't
answer sufficiently so um and I didn't
start this conversation as an opponent
to what's been happening in Florida I
started this conversation as a concerned
person who has seen the cataclysmic
effects of this radical leftist ideology
especially in higher education but now
increasingly in K through 12 and is is
hoping on all fronts that something can
be done about it and so I'm
I'm much more what would you say uh
convinced much more reassured that you
and the people who are doing this have
thought this through to the to the
proper level of detail so and if I have
other questions that pop up and no doubt
there will be some then I'll be more
than happy to you know let those be
known I'd like to think about what I'm
doing in this conversation as a
benevolent critic you know I because
this is so important to get this right
that I don't want to see anybody slip up
and you guys are taking very forthright
action and
hopefully there aren't any snakes
lurking under the carpet right because
I'm always looking for snakes lurking
and lurking under the carpet and so far
in this conversation today you haven't
revealed any new snakes so that's pretty
much how I look at that look at that
situation so look we should we should
wrap this up
um we've gone for a requisite 90 minutes
and like I said you you made a pretty
damn compelling closing statement there
I appreciate very much you taking the
time to walk through this with me today
and for you to share what you've been
doing no so forth rightly with everybody
who's listening and watching I'm sure
there'll be plenty of people uh paying
careful attention especially parents who
should particularly pay attention to
this conversation who are you know
interested in what's happening in
Florida and elsewhere but also leery
about it and so my suspicions are
they're going to feel a lot more
confident about
this attempt to restructure than they
might have before the conversation so
that's probably a success on your front
I guess we'll see what the public
commentary is like so I'd like to thank
you very much for agreeing to talk to me
today to everybody who's watching and
listening
on YouTube and its Associated platforms
thanks for your time and attention to
the Daily wire plus people for
facilitating this conversation that's
much appreciated film crew here in Tulsa
because that's where I am today who made
this possible uh without any technical
flaw or screw-up that's always much
appreciated and Chris we're going to
move over to the Daily wire plus
platform now and I'm going to spend half
an hour with you talking more
autobiographically I'm interested in
getting into a little bit more detail
about how your your intellectual
interests developed across time and I'm
I'm thanks again for agreeing to talk to
me it was a pleasure getting to know you
a bit more
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com